Well, tonight wraps up our first week
here at the Largo Theater,
wonderful comedy theater in Los Angeles
and we're so happy that we
could take over this space.
I'm doing this in the safest way possible.
We have just very few crew
members working around me.
Everyone's wearing masks.
Everyone is socially distanced.
And everyone has been tested, yeah.
As an added precaution it was my idea
that all crew members be sterilized.
I was told this was not necessary,
but I really don't want them having kids.
Anyway, moving on, the entire audience,
as you can imagine, is empty,
except for my trusty assistant, Sona,
always by my side.
Hey Sona, how's it going?
Hey Conan, it's good.
Why are you so much further back
than you were the other time?
You're practically out in the lobby.
Why are you back that way?
I think if I want to leave
to go do something or get something,
I thought it would be better
if I was closer to this
door than that one.
Why would you leave when
I'm shooting a show?
This is exciting.
Um, I don't know.
I want food, maybe a sandwich,
go get some ramen.
You'd go get ramen while
I'm shooting a show?
I mean, yeah.
I figured I'd just slip out
and you probably wouldn't even notice.
How do you think the show's going so far?
I think it's good.
I was looking at my phone.
(Sona laughing)
Nice to have an audience.
Thanks, Sona.